I've heard a lot about the negative impacts of oxalates.
Should we be watching or oxalate intake?
So, first of all, can oxalates cause health problems?
Yes, so what are oxalates? It's a type of biochemical that's found in different foods.
Like, rhubarb has a lot of oxalates.
Green leafy vegetables have a lot of oxalates.
Spinach has a lot of oxalates.
Kale has a lot of oxalates.
Well, should we stay away from oxalates?
Because I heard that oxalates can be bad.
Well, they can be bad for some people.
So, there are in your genetic summary, some people have defects on their genes that help
produce enzymes to get rid of oxalates.
Those people have a much greater chance of having negative impacts of oxalates.
Many of the stones, the kidney stones, and even some gallstones can be oxalate-based stones.
So, typically, people that are prone to kidney stones or gallstones or even liver stones
are people that have defects on those oxalate genes.
And if that was your case, I would have told you that you should limit oxalates
because you have defects on those genes.
To be honest, it's not at least what we have seen in the population of cancer that we see.
I haven't seen very many people with oxalate, genetic oxalate issues.
It doesn't mean that it doesn't exist.
I just, it's not as common.
Maybe it's not as common with some people with cancer.
I don't know.
So, I don't see this a lot.
So, oxalates, having issues with oxalates are not a food sensitivity, per se.
It's that you don't get rid of them well.
You're not binding them well.
Typically, oxalates would be bound in the gut and you wouldn't absorb very many of them.
But people could have genetic defects where they don't buy
oxalates, they absorb them, they have excess oxalates, and they have having issues.
You can see this also on the organic acid test.
The people have oxalate issues that will always show up there
and then the genetic test.
But when I say that because I saw a video about the negative impact of oxalates that I
get to really go on an oxalate-free diet, no, I would not do that.
Just, you know, there's all sorts of chemicals in different foods that can be a problem for some
people, but it's usually a small percentage of the population that have that issue,
and then they have to be careful with that.